whoa
like the spartan sheen of its digital
environments volume is self that it's
most fundamental level
it's a fine-tuned equation and aside
from several threatening variables not
much can upset its balance volume is a
futuristic retelling of the classic
Robin Hood legend it takes place in
simulations filled with labyrinthian
corridors and enemy guards in which our
hero Rob Locksley broadcasts
hypothetical heists against corrupt
corporations there are trip lasers alarm
panels and automated tourists to
traverse it's our job not only to
navigate these hazards but also collect
a certain number of floating gems these
unlock and exit portal place somewhere
in the environment and this puts a
creative twist on the classic stealth
formula imagine Solid Snake of Metal
Gear Fame thrown into pac-man with only
a few gadgets and his bare hands to help
him survive slinking through these
booby-trapped mazes is as much about
careful traversal as patient observation
and observation is important because
volume is just as much a puzzle game as
it is a member of the stealth genre most
levels don't leave room for
improvisation instead guiding you with
visual clues and subtle hints toward the
exit the fun in volume doesn't lie in
choosing your favorite approach but
finally discovering the one that works
volume has a clean simple visual
vocabulary which never leaves anything
open to interpretation it places
function over form and by definition
that's good design guard vision cones
are always visible electrified tiles are
apparent and lasers emit a bright white
streak these lasers can lead to frequent
restarts as your character sometimes
keeps moving after you let go of the
computer key or analog stick but it
didn't happen often enough to prolong
the frustration even volumes audio cues
emit a white circle using these to
manipulate guards is essential and
learning them from their positions is
only a matter of whistling there are
also gadgets to aid in distractions the
white circles are precise and never
leave any doubt as to whether guards
would hear you or not ironic as it is in
a game called volume I could have
finished it with the sound turned off
volume also features simple deep and
accessible editing tools I created
several maps that proved challenging and
it didn't take me long to learn how the
different tools work these levels don't
end up telling the story the campaign
does but I think that's for the better
volume makes an attempt at broad social
commentary about modern internet culture
protagonists locksley broadcast has
simulated heist a thousand
followers and his growing popularity is
a clear examination of let's play videos
that have come to dominate YouTube
culture but volume never seems to say
anything in the process its story is
disjointed with some characters only
present for dozens of seconds before
being pushed back behind the curtain I
don't see the deposed Queen I don't see
silences I try to warn you the cutscenes
also feel force and I would rather the
developer avoid a story altogether it
often got in the way of the gameplay
with subtitles obscuring important
information before I turn them off
characters also repeated monologues ad
nauseam at checkpoints and their
constant chatter removed me from the
tense stealth game I was trying to focus
on and it is fantastic
there's actual cooldown toys people
still say but when you're able to avoid
the barrier that the overarching
narrative creates volume flows from one
level to the next with the aptitude of a
great stealth game and the inventiveness
of a clever puzzle title